encore trois semaines donc à tenir avant
de pouvoir à nouveau fouler la moquette
d'une salle de cinéma s'émerveiller
devant une toile de maître ou tout
simplement assister à un spectacle en
plein air ou en intérieur
après six mois de fermeture les lieux
culturels vont retrouver un semblant de
vie à partir du 19 mai prochain
un soulagement pour les professionnels
du secteur aurélie renault au studio on
est près du 19 mai au 9 juin
la jauge serait de 35 % dans la salle
l'équipe est très enthousiaste à l'idée
d'ouvrir consciente qu'il faudra adapter
les horaires des séances pour coller au
couvre-feu
côté programmation les distributeurs
seraient unis ce lundi
on sait qu'on va avoir les films adieu
les cons mandibules garçons chiffon qui
avait été notre dernière présentation
avec un réalisateur
donc cela on va continuer l'exploitation
à partir de lundi on sait qu'on va
reprendre les contacts avec les
distributeurs et le ne sommes absolument
pas inquiet sur le fait qu'on aura une
sélection diverses et variées comme on a
l'habitude de le faire
par contre sans doute pas de grandes
sorties nationales ça viendra plus tard
au centre de création contemporaine ont
pallié la fermeture par des visites à
travers les grandes baies vitrées de la
nef pour renouer immédiatement avec le
public
le centre décide d'amorcer une opération
d confinement dans un premier temps on
prévoit d'accueillir gratuitement le
public pour quelques jours et ensuite on
prévoit également d'offrir quelque chose
pour nos abonnés et aussi pour les
remercier de nous soutenir
château de tours opéra musée pour des
confiner ces structures qui
appartiennent à la ville
il va falloir rapatrier des agents
municipaux ce que peuvent rouvrir
il faut mettre en place les protocoles
sanitaires il faut remobiliser des
agents qui avaient été affectés au
centre de vaccination ou dans des écoles
donc faut remettre tout ça en place
installée depuis début mars et les
intermittents du spectacle et les
travailleurs précaires devrait ainsi
quitter le grand théâtre de tours afin
d'accueillir à nouveau le public